[Music]
thank you
Sacha thank you for joining spectator TV
thank you to start we've had 13 years of
Tory rule how is the NHS doing now
well the NHS is getting record amounts
of funding it's dealing with more people
and more patients than ever before this
history it's got more doctors and nurses
than ever before it's had to deal with a
a pandemic which we haven't seen the
likes of for decades and so in many
senses it's it's doing well in terms of
looking after so many people but when
you compare the NHS to other Universal
Health Care Systems in countries we
often compare ourselves to our neighbors
in Europe or Australia Japan and other
places the health outcomes which
ultimately I think is what matters in
most to people are definitely not as
good as they should be you've become
very vocal recently about calling for
Change and calling for reform of the NHS
what has propelled you to do that
well after having been Health secretary
as well as having obviously other jobs
in government which I was dealing with
the the Department of Health and Social
care it's uh it's it's become more of a
challenge I think because of the
pandemic but even before the pandemic I
think we could see because of an aging
Society because of the the changes in
the burden of disease especially since
the NHS was created because of the
expectations that people rightly have
for the latest drugs and treatments so
we've seen the surge in demand and uh
Supply hasn't been keeping up and I
think yeah when we all sort of look at
it and we do an honest assessment the
fact that so many people are waiting for
GPS they're waiting for a e they're
waiting for ambulances they're waiting
for scans and operations you know that's
not it's far from ideal and I think we
have to then look at that and and think
to ourselves you know when funding is at
such a record high that what are the
causes of this how come other countries
aren't facing necessarily the same
issues in delivery when they all have
the same challenges of rising demand and
I think we have to you as politicians
you'll be honest in our assessment and
instead of what I think sometimes is a
sort of politicians also leaning into
you know adulation competing with each
other is to say look you know where the
NHS works well great but if it doesn't
work well if it's not delivering what
British people would rightly expect we
should be honest and and have an
assessment and have a serious debate
about its future and what's the best way
to make it fit for the future I remember
when you became Health secretary you
made
not wearing that NHS badge that many
Health secretaries before did and I seem
to recall that the suggestion was you
know I I don't want to be glorifying the
system I I want to see what works and
what doesn't for doctors and nurses and
patients and the rest but you are by no
means as vocal as you are now about the
necessary reform that you think needs to
take place what is going so wrong in the
political discussion that it takes an MP
who was he was leading the Health
Service but has now announced that
they're going to be stepping down and
not running for re-election that only at
that point do politicians tend to feel
comfortable to start talking about this
stuff
well I think for yeah and you're right
it is about politicians it's not one
particular party I think all the major
political parties uh have been the you
really when it comes to the NHS just
sort of focusing on on almost treating
it like a religion like the rest of the
countries though you know it's above
criticism and at the end of the day we
must remember it's a it's a Health
Service uh and it's every obviously for
all of us but what we want out of it are
the best outcomes and I think where
politicians get stuck really is that
they are very afraid uh to speak
honestly and openly about the challenge
of the NHS and how to fix them because
frankly they just don't want to get
their head shot off they just feel that
they think that's not what the public
want to hear but interestingly you know
I I've started you know talking about
the NHS a lot recently as you say about
the the future of it I'm deeply
concerned about it
um just the the last couple of days I
wrote about it in in in the times and
elsewhere and I can tell you just today
I had I've had so many emails from
people from the public you know coming
into me unsolicited about my comments
the vast majority in support of what I'm
saying which is let's have an honest
debate let's have a royal commission but
interestingly when I was looking at them
earlier today the the vast majority of
support but most of those that are in
support from people working inside the
NHS doctors nurses Consultants inside
the NHS uh talking about this and and
saying you know it's great that you know
you Sergeant you know Tony Blair today
and others are openly talking about the
kind of things that need to change
another politic talking about change is
Shadow Health secretary Wes streeting
does it worry you as a Tory MP that
labor might be bolder on this topic and
might be offering up more solutions come
the next general election than your own
party no not really look I I want to see
a NHS that's fit for the future and I
think to get there we are going to need
new politicians on all sides to to work
together you know one of one of the
things that we've had in this country
for many many years is a sort of
settlement let's say on the NHS are
political settlement and and by and
large for many years that's that serve
the country well up until you know more
recently where these challenges that we
now face that sort of settlement almost
is stopping an honest debate but going
forward if we don't want the NHS to be
used as a day-to-day political football
I think getting all politicians to agree
that they are you know some serious
problems that it does require an honest
assessment
Way Forward now I think the way forward
is a royal commission
um I I read the other day west region is
saying it's not the whole commission but
I I think that you know actually getting
all partitions to agree to a way forward
to an honest assessment with uh with
experts as well as politicians involved
and then when this war commission
reports back having uh the government of
the day make the decisions in a as it
should in a proper Democratic fashion is
the Right Way Forward I want to ask you
a little bit about money because again
you were house secretary you will have
had detailed understanding about how
much money is really funneled into the
Health Service I think it's now
approaching about 44 of Public Service
day-to-day spending
um I think there's this almost Universal
assumption that one of the struggles for
the NHS is that it was so badly
underfunded by Tory governments during
the years of austerity but if you look
back and you look at government only
spending the NHS consistently ranks in
the top four countries in the Oe ecd's
rankings for government only spending do
you think that money is the problem do
you think the system is the problem one
thing I'm curious about is whether or
not the system is actually stopping more
money from going in because if we look
at these other Universal systems they're
much more pragmatic about combining
State and private sector money to top up
their Health Service yeah the the NHS as
we know relies almost entirely on
taxpayer funding unlike as you've
rightly pointed out many of the well
actually all other Universal Health Care
Systems so when we talk about contract
Germany and France and Italy and Japan
right all of them right now they're all
all those countries by the way by having
a Universal Health Care System unlike
let's say United States which is a
system I would not want to see anything
like that here in the UK If you compare
ourselves to other just other European
countries is the as you say they have
funding for multiple sources now the
Lion's Share is probably still coming
from the state State one way or the
other but people are able to contribute
in almost all those countries they
contribute in a means-tested way so the
end result of that is that as a value I
think we can all sign up to which is
that uh anyone in a country no matter
who they are should get you know
world-class Health Care uh but based on
their needs you know based on their you
know their means and their ability right
so your means should not hold you back
from getting uh the care uh that you
need and so that's how these countries
have approached it what happens in the
UK and I haven't seen this just from the
perspective as a health secretary but as
Chancellor as well is that when at any
chance that when they're allocating uh
funding of course there's many other
trade-offs to be made you know you need
to what about education what about
especially now defense costs are going
up interest rates are going up you know
all of those need Government funding as
well so inevitably there's trade-offs
and a transfer will look at the biggest
budget in your in in government the NHS
and inevitably the NHS will have to be a
consequence of that trade-off so it the
the to avoid that to some extent you
know I think having a look at other
models of care and how they're funded is
is the right thing uh to do uh but also
uh is to you when you look at the
overall funding is to realize that it's
not a question of funding in the other
countries with less funding seem to be
getting better outcomes so you have to
look at the model and you have to look
at many other aspects of healthcare I
think it's very interesting that you've
had so many people writing to you since
your comments and the times
um saying that they broadly speaking
agree with you how do you process
getting these messages from patients who
are having a tough time with the sites
that we saw this week at Westminster
Abbey with politicians praying over the
NHS doing readings essentially giving
sermons I mean in my mind it really
doesn't add up
well I I think there is when you look at
the NHS especially over the 75-year
history I think when we're especially
we're if we're talking about the people
that work in the NHS the doctors the
nurses consultants and yeah anyone who's
working the NHS in any capacity I think
these people are are in my experience
they are people that work incredibly
hard they're incredibly dedicated
they're compassionate caring people but
they are working within the structures
that have been created for them
ultimately by politicians of of of many
parties successive governments and that
broad structure of the NHS hasn't
changed when the world around it has
changed dramatically and so the the the
the people in the NHS yeah I think they
do deserve thanks for doing what they do
but I think if we are to properly
support them we must realize the the the
the the the challenges that they work in
can be you know alleviated to a huge
extent if we as politicians take a
dispassionate look at the NHS and the
structures last question uh
very well into 20
because we were looking to lift
restrictions and go back to normal life
I know you weren't there at the height
of lockdown yeah and a lot of what we're
seeing now especially with these record
waiting lists as a result of people
staying at home and treatments vastly
delayed do you think in retrospect that
stay-at-home messaging to protect the
NHS was a mistake
um I don't know in terms of um the the
the the nature of your question because
I don't think we have enough data yet in
the the NHS has compared to other
countries has less capacity when you
look at it in terms of beds versus say
you know Germany has something like
seven uh your beds per thousand when we
have two or three when you look at it in
terms of your scanning equipment and
your number of doctors and nurses it has
less capacity than most other European
countries can intentionally run that way
to stay and if you run that because the
NHS is is running about 95 capacity when
in most of the countries in Europe they
went around 80 85 capacity so when it
was already running at a very high sort
of rate before the pandemic hit I I
think you know obviously I wasn't there
at the time but I could understand
reasons as to why the decisions that
were made were made I I think I don't
want to even though I've been there as
health secretary you're doing half the
pandemic let's say I don't want to
really second guess the decisions that
were made at the time because I don't
feel I have all the information
thanks for joining spectator TV good
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you